okay my understanding of what cop21 is
it's a series of meetings in which
politicians get together to make a
global agreement on limiting greenhouse
gas emissions cop stands for the
conference of the parties and it's the
concert the parties of the united
nations framework convention on climate
change which is the international
agreement designed to get us towards
emission cuts of stabilized climate
there as suggested in the name have been
a number of these meetings over the
years and there still isn't a global
agreement on mitigating and reducing
emissions of greenhouse gases so what's
up to the first 20 meetings not as much
as we'd like first of all and there was
a lot of progress initially and the
Kyoto Protocol came into effect was
actually penned in 97 I think it came
into effect once enough of the fraction
the emitters were signed up and I was
when the Russians signed up I think in
the sort of early 2000 mid-2000s so it
came into effect and the first round of
emissions commitments cup Commission's
ran I think until 2012 we're still
waited for the next set so in a sense
there was a lot of progress initially
and a lot of promise and as the first
the first phase of commitments has timed
out we've had I've ever delay now before
making progress on next so what tends to
happen is that there are massive
documents all with square brackets
around text which does not exist and the
main purpose of the meeting as far as I
could tell was to remove some of these
square brackets so to get agreement
across the wall all the countries and
has to be agreement by all the countries
this is perhaps the problem of the
double process I think because there's a
there's reasons for the different
parties to excuse themselves so the
Americans always an excuse themselves
because the Chinese weren't coming on
board you know the Canadians would we're
doing likewise even in Europe there's
always this thing about well how do you
balance economic development with
emissions cuts you know even with the UK
i'm in the UK for example we we've taken
the moral
my ground attracted moral high ground on
this but we started holding off from it
deliberately but when we started our
industrial revolution we were the first
imitates and we taught everyone else had
to emit co2 there's actually quite hard
for any one group to take a position
that doesn't potentially disadvantage
them you know we're talking about
potential economic stakeholders in
impotent potential economic implications
of reducing emissions switching to other
forms of generating electricity for
example and you know many of the
developing countries in the world are
struggling to develop let alone having
to implement green technologies I mean
the UK will fight for no we're not going
back to the beginning of time working on
emissions because it won't be good for
them and others might say well yeah
we're hold on a minute you know if
you're in good Chinese say we've got a
load more carbon to burn before or
anywhere new you guys so you can see how
when you a negotiating and negotiation
is not about the truth actually it's
just about what can be agreed that you
can get stuck you know it's not someone
once said to me when I went last went to
a cop this is not the time to introduce
science it's interesting thing but I'd
soph believe it you know when you're in
a negotiation say you're buying a
t-shirt on market store you don't want
someone to come in and say oh by the way
the real value of that t-shirts three
pounds when he's just about degree 450
you know means not in anyone's interest
so there is a there is a dangerous there
was a dangerous thing here about about
that boundary between science which is
about objected to four tries to be and
politics which is never like that it's
always of our negotiation a best there's
inertia both in the climate system and
in the political system takes time
things to change a crucial variable is
the cumulative amount of emissions that
have been omitted so it's not the
eventual level of warming that will be
attained is proportional to the
cumulative so as we accumulate emissions
we committing ourselves to a higher
warning so the the longer we put off
making the decision and implementing
something to limit greenhouse gases the
higher the level of warning warning
we're committed to so cop21 is is being
held up with with more optimism than any
cop since the Copenhagen meeting in 2009
where many climate scientists and those
wanting action on climate change thought
we might actually get a proper agreement
and it didn't quite happen so there is
more hope this time around but I think
as as the years have gone by and the
cops of tick by we've also got kind of
weary of this optimism pessimism cycles
so you won't see that peaks of optimism
that we saw in 2009 I don't think people
will be much more cynical about what
will be achieved I suppose the really
positive thing is we're still talking
you know the leaders still feel it's
worth them going there they want to be
seen to be acting on climate change
Obama recently with the Keystone
pipeline you know made a big a brave
decision that's not going to be
politically very comfortable for him so
there is them a sense that a subset of
world leaders want to really deal with
this problem and leave as a kind of as a
legacy for future generations they
sorted it out but it's tough it's really
tough to get agreement on these sort of
things the earth will warm by 2 to 4
degrees we just can't nail it down any
better than that this the science is
fairly complicated there are lots of
things that happen to the carbon so it's
just a problem we have to live with that
we don't know whether it's two degrees
or four degrees or off into the future
whether it's four degrees or eight
degrees